il y a moins de trois mois après une
attaque maimouna mohamed quitte son
village situé dans la zone de ménaka au
mali
j'entendais avant des villages qui se
faisait attaquer les bandits tuer les
gens et voler leur bétail mais cette
fois ci c'était nous
j'ai dû fuir avec mes deux enfants sans
mon mari
ça nous a pris une journée entière pour
venir ici à ouallam on a dormi dans la
brousse avant de venir au camp bucca
près de douze mille réfugiés sont
hébergés dans le camp de ouallam qui est
en place depuis 2020 une partie des
réfugiés préfèrent poursuivre le chemin
jusqu'à la capitale nigérienne hors des
camps certains tente de rebâtir leur
communauté
zac ou karimou était chef d'un village
malien situé près de la frontière entre
les deux pays
bonjour que la paix soit avec vous
les gens avec qui j'ai fille jusqu'ici
ils me considèrent toujours comme leur
chef mais aux alentours et puis dans
niamey on ne se sent même pas pris en
compte
comme à trouer maimouna la plupart des
réfugiés maliens doivent traverser le
nord de la région de tillabéri l'une des
zones les plus dangereuses du pays ils
ont touché ce qui était peut-être le la
zone la plus proche de l'éruption
volcanique pourrait être à la périphérie
mais sinon des attaques à walla sont
possibles des attaques sont possibles
partout dans toutes les villes du niger
et dans toutes les villes des trois pays
bas air burkina faso mali qui c'est la
même situation
au mali les récents affrontements entre
groupes armés ont une nouvelle fois
poussé plusieurs milliers d'habitants à
l'exil au moins soixante mille maliens
qui ont fui cette violence vivent
actuellement au niger